there are certain Americans dead or
alive who are regarded as national
treasures John Wayne Katharine Hepburn
Louis Armstrong Walter Cronkite Joe
Lewis Babe Ruth and of course Alfred
Newman this fictional face that launched
35 years of Mad Magazine you might have
thought that with all the electronic
diversions available to kids today
something like mad would be if not
already dead then certainly die that was
1987 this week we learned that Mad
Magazine will cease publishing new
material after its fall issue was
released launched by William Games in
1952 as a comic book mad soon became a
satirical magazine never fearing to take
on the establishment whether it was
politicians pop culture advertising or
the minutiae of daily life we pride
ourselves in the fact that we have no
philosophy we have no philosophy we have
no politics we don't take sides with its
mascot
Alfred E Newman leading the way and
recurring features like spy versus spy
mad hits peak in the 1970s with more
than 2 million subscribers and even more
in newsstand sales but like many other
magazines mads subscribers dwindled in
the 21st century in 2017 MADD moved from
its home office in New York City to Los
Angeles where it relaunched with a new
issue number one
but once issue number 10 is released mad
will only publish archival material and
new issues will only be sold in comic
book shops and through subscriptions
excuse me is this Mad Magazine
now it's Mademoiselle we're buying a
sign on the installment plan after 67
years and more than 550 issues
mads influence is undeniable hey do you
see the parody of The Daily Show in this
month's Mad Magazine no I didn't see
that - are you a new one buddy
among those crediting Mad with inspiring
them Jerry Seinfeld Howard Stern rocker
Patti Smith political activist Tom
Hayden movie critic Roger Ebert
[Music]
and weird al' yankovic guest-edited an
issue of Matt in 2015 he wrote on
Twitter Matt is pretty much the reason I
turned out weird over wine from games
right we have we have no philosophy we
have no morals no scruples right what's
so good the number of people it's
inspired is pretty remarkable
I remember it well I remember my dad
telling me he was a big fan